what's up you guys it's Friday yes
Friday anything new uh I just put up the
Hellraiser review earlier so thanks
again to Dominic for sending us that and
I'm sorry it took so long for us to get
around to it we're working on a youtube
thing yeah we're at the paid thing yeah
yeah we're gonna do that so I'm gonna do
cuz I think you have to do like a
specific little video for that like
saying what the membership [ __ ] is so
we'll probably do that as well um let's
see I watched last night I'm trying to
think of the [ __ ] that I watched last
night so I finished out the series
apparently shudder I thought they were
gonna put up like the cursed film series
I thought they were doing like one a
week like they were doing with Creepshow
but apparently they decided [ __ ] it and
they just that's three up there like the
last couple days so apparently all five
episodes are up there now I think that's
all the absences they're doing I have to
say that the last three were a big
improvement like on the first two
because I feel like the first two
episodes which were The Exorcist and The
Omen we're good but I feel like there
was only like 10 minutes worth of
content about the movies and then the
rest of stuff was just about kind of
general [ __ ] you know I mean like
talking about magical thinking and about
curses in general and stuff which is
interesting but it I wish that had
focused more on the movies so I'm happy
to report that the last three which were
about poltergeist The Crow and Twilight
Zone the movie which we reviewed not too
long ago actually concentrated almost
exclusively on the movies which was nice
to say so like they did go in-depth the
poltergeist one still had some kind of a
little bit of general [ __ ] in there but
um other than that was good and the crow
one was pretty much all about Brandon
Lee and about Bruce Lee and about like
the curse around the family like people
saying about that and [ __ ] and they're
talking to like people that have worked
on the film and you know the accident
that happened and there was other
accidents on the on the set that
happened to which I wasn't even aware of
it's a pretty good series yeah but it
definitely got better as it went along
yeah there's the first two were a bit
weak you could tell that they're I think
they're made by different people and
kind of like throwbacks to the 90s this
one was good though I like this one
I don't know if you guys remember we did
the review of the movie the Dare which
we liked and I was talking about this
German actor named Robert Mazur yeah
it's not going up till Sunday but yes
it's not going up until Sunday but I
mentioned it on the other side trek and
he was also played the German pilot that
jumped out the dev Walker and foot on
fire and shot the dude if he saw 1917
anyway I messaged him and told him I
said that man I thought he'd make a
great Flash Gordon and he got back to me
right he's so excited yeah thank you for
reaching out I appreciate your words I
love the idea of Flash Gordon and then
he's got like a smiley face and a thumbs
up there's all the best to you rob so
and I told him I'd send him the review
when it's ready but yeah that's good
that's cool that he reached out to
somebody who you know said Maggie make a
[ __ ] great Flash Gordon yeah well I
just thought was the first thing I
thought of like when I saw his face like
that you just reminded me of maybe he
reminded me of the actor that played him
in the serial or from the comic yeah cuz
he doesn't look like the guy that night
him in you know them no he looks like an
old school flash yeah that's how I was
thinking like he looked very much like a
throwback type of and he's one of the
few guys they got right now that to me
the physicality tells me a man of action
yeah yeah I mean you're right yeah
action star alpha male hero type or like
he played a good villain too in there
there yeah yeah either way but guy
that's just like a big [ __ ] kind of
like male models what he looks like but
he's a stuntman you not I mean he's
backing it up it's not a tenant gymnast
it's not just looks you know he's just a
[ __ ] uber Mitch yeah cuz like I said
I was surprised when I looked him up
like I wasn't surprised to do as a stunt
man cuz he's big and buff and everything
but he got his start like as a gymnast
and is actually won like a bunch of
titles yeah he's got a lot of
conditioning you can see it you know
just just [ __ ] Finch
[ __ ] Google him I mean dude looks
like just a [ __ ] prime physical
specimen and that's and that's the way
flash was drawn that's what yeah I think
that's what reminded me of it because
I've seen like the serials and all the
kind of the original comics and all that
other kind of stuff yeah but yeah so
yeah so cursed films good I watched a
couple like last night I was kind of
like I didn't really know what I was in
the mood to watch so I rewatched starry
eyes which I have recommended many times
on this show probably it's from 2014 and
it's on shudder might also be on Netflix
and to be its own like a whole bunch of
different streaming services so if you
haven't seen it you might want to check
it out I also got into watching and I
should have watched this probably before
we did the show on Lizzie Borden that we
didn't you months ago I watched the
movie Lizzie I can't remember what moot
what year it was from it's can't be that
old because Kristen Stewart was in it
and Chloe 7u was in it and they went the
route of the two of them that Bridget
and and Lizzie Borden were kind of like
in love with each other having a sexual
relationship and kind of like wanted to
kill the parents because Andrew Borden
was molesting or raping the maid and
also was just a [ __ ] in general so I
mean I and and they also went with the
whole like Lizzie was naked when she
killed them and that's why there was
like no blood on the clothes and stuff
now originally what they did in this
movie was that Bridget was supposed to
kill Andrew but she chickened out so
Lizzie ended up killing both of them
anyway
but then you know Bridget went on the
stand and like covered for her ass and
stuff like that so the so the you know
this movie was saying that they both
were like conspiring and they both knew
what happened however they also painted
the Borden's as like so horrible that I
was just kind of like yeah kill him like
this [ __ ] that the dad did of this I'm
like you have my dad s tentatively
killed it looked to me it looked like a
very kind of standard movie of its type
of me
didn't really pull me in but it didn't
look bad it looked good it wasn't a
horror movie
it is on shudder but they have like
other [ __ ] on there too it's more like a
like a psychological horror that's like
a drama yeah it did have some real gory
like cuz they showed like when she
[ __ ] axed Andrew in the face and then
like they showed a nice big close-up of
his [ __ ] cleaved face and it was like
really good stuff but um other than like
a few moments in it it's pretty much
just a straight drama for me I was never
really interested in that case I think
that's what it was a lot people like wow
what happened I really I don't really
care
the-the-the the case was actually pretty
typical there were a lot of murders like
that over the years they went unsolved
where they were suspects but you know I
mean it I don't know why I don't know
why this one stands out so much in
people's minds and in culture a lot of
these I've always kind of wondered that
about a lot of crimes why some crimes
you know get a lot of like attention and
another crime that's almost exactly like
yeah it's like you don't hear anything
about it I know I don't know if it's
just because I think it's because the
suspect was a woman and they were middle
class and it was Boston area yeah they
were like up there were kind of
upper-class they were kind of like upper
society type of people and I think
that's the only reason why it might have
been and also because there was so much
evidence to suggest that Lizzie had
probably done it but then she got off
with it and she was kind of a weird
character anyway so maybe that kind of
like fueled the whole thing I've always
wondered that too about like why
somebody like you know like Jack the
Ripper and I might have mentioned this
on one of our other shows like somebody
like Jack the Ripper is still remembered
like more than a hundred years after the
crimes took place even though there have
been other unsolved crimes that don't
like that that are kind of like that are
just as brutal or they killed more
people or something like that's even
worse
yeah and they kind of get reshot about
so it's just really interesting to me
and I can't really put my finger on what
it is maybe that like just has to be
some little detail that people latch on
to place in time yeah it is the timing
and the location it was and I think the
Lizzie Borden case was built back then
in those days and
was just a media circus and it stuck
like the Lindbergh case yeah nowadays
that brought you you'd probably pretty
much forget about that case pretty
quickly yeah that's true I mean well
yeah they're media driven that's the
thing it's it's what ya thinks will sell
a good story and that case will be
remembered if the media doesn't think
they can sell sell a bunch of papers and
can't make up a good story then the case
will be forgotten yeah if it doesn't
have like some salacious details or
theories or something behind it that
people can latch on to like that a damn
Italian case where the guys right in the
damn fake news are like let's make it
seem like the mother did it yeah that
was it yeah yeah that was uh that was I
think the Gregory Bay you maintained
right the little Gregory yeah don't
believe in you hear in the news those
[ __ ] a lot man well I'm gonna say
don't believe anything ever yeah I mean
usually you have to believe some things
obviously but it's your own research to
make their own damn opinion your own
damn opinion on this [ __ ] a lot of that
a lot of that stuff that you and then in
the newspapers it's all just about
selling the next newspaper well that's
not new it's been going on since yes
seven hundreds it's been going on since
forever
yeah the thing is it's like you can't
just automatically disbelieve everything
because there are some kernels of truth
in there but you just have to take
everything with a grain of salt and be
like okay well this particular detail is
there any reason that they would have
put this in here and maybe it's not true
or maybe I just not I mean I just always
look for contradictions in the narrative
you know they're you know they're
spinning the [ __ ] yarn when the story
shoots down the its own story when yours
contradictions going on you know I mean
or when there's contradictions in the
narrative that's when I know they're
just they're just [ __ ] bullshitting
well it's something that I've been like
thinking about last couple days because
I've been researching I went back and
was like revisiting some of the remember
we did the show a long time ago with
those about the smiley face murder and
stuff well I've been researching I'm not
gonna spoil it although maybe if you
know anything about anything that you'll
probably figure out what I'm doing
because um the next podcast episode that
we're doing I'm gonna cover one case
that's similar to that
and so I've been kind of looking into
how these things occur like how these
urban legends kind of you know rise up
around these types of things
and it's just really really interesting
to me that you would think that now that
we have so much information right at our
fingertips that that would largely go
away but it seems like it's I don't know
if I'd say it was worse but it's much
easier for information true or false to
be generated you know and it's much
easier to like be disseminated like out
to the public so it does seem like a lot
of [ __ ] about conspiracy theories and
you know maybe links between things that
aren't there I think that can spread a
lot quicker than it used to back in the
old days even though and - there's like
there's like the thing where there's
kind of you know where you're steered
like in one direction like what just
information that agrees with what you
already agree with and you tend to like
get new sources that pop up in your feed
and [ __ ] like that that are only kind of
tailored to your viewpoint I'm gonna
start making your own narrative as you
go and then you start going down this
way but you're losing like the larger
perspective so there is that problem -
but like I said I don't know if there's
any way to combat that really just
because that's the way human brains work
you know there's confirmation bias
there's you know you tend to like
remember things that agree with what you
already think and forget things that
don't yeah and there's all these kind of
like things in that so but yeah so one
case that I've been you know kind of
researching for the show brought a
little bit a bit of that out so I'll
probably talk a little bit about more
about that on that yeah but what you're
talking about a lot conspiracy theories
are like that and like there are some
conspiracy theories going around that I
just can't buy you know what I mean
about you know child sacrifice and
people taking the damn stuff that comes
out of damn pituitary gland and making
drugs out of it i buy adrenochrome right
and that you know what I mean
high-ranking DSC officials are involved
in that I just don't buy it I don't
think they could hide it all right but
then there are others there's other
stuff that I think that you know there's
something to it like I did like I told
you I told you that this that this virus
came from something that they were
working on you know people all know is
natural it's starting to come out now
now it's links to that damn lab in Wuhan
and there's Americans that are linked to
that lab too they were working on
something I don't know if it was a
bioweapon remember the day the outbreak
this is back when it was still in Wuhan
I said I could just see the way the
Chinese government reacted I said they
know what that is that they went right
into unto a mop level which is mission
oriented protective posture they're
trying to as I said that must be
dangerous they know exactly what it is
it's some kind of a bioweapon or
something that can affect a situation in
the same way a bio weapon you can we did
a show on a long time ago about the
deniability of them and the fact that
you can attack somebody and say I didn't
do it you know it was natural cause they
went through that whole thing now it's
starting to come out past two days yeah
it did come from there you know I mean
it's their the the Chinese are starting
to kind of like almost admit it but you
know we'll see and it didn't have to be
on purpose was it on purpose I don't
know
the timing was awful suspicious the
timing was awful suspicious I think we
might find out more and you know you
could say well that's a conspiracy
theory a lot of [ __ ] that really happens
you could say as a conspiracy theory you
know I mean conspiracy theory the term
made up by intelligence organizations to
hide the [ __ ] that they did to explain
it away so I don't know it's just the
worries we're gonna see we're to say
what do you think Jenny um I I don't
think that you don't think what I don't
I don't believe that theory that it was
just that it was man-made or that it
came out of a lab work on purpose or
anything like that there are some Indian
universities I mean the reason the
reason that they had like a quick
response to it is because they've had
almost exactly this types of flu
outbreaks before and so probably know
how to deal with it they're like oh [ __ ]
is another one just like that there was
evidently some Indian laboratories that
got a sample of it and to them they said
that they believed it to be engineered
that it was a chimera it was made up of
a couple different things and that
evidently the Indian government believes
that it may have been done on purpose
well I don't know I'm just saying I
don't believe that well you know there
was a trade war going on with China they
were uh there was a rebellion going on
in Hong Kong then they were having a lot
of problems with Taiwan evidently it
looks like they're poised to do a
military invasion of Taiwan right now
this would be a perfect smokescreen for
all that it just that timing is just
[ __ ] suspicious and I don't believe
in suspicious timing I was involved in
military operations military operations
always have suspicious timing it's just
I'm not a trusting person
you know that's just that's my I'm at
either but I'm a very logical person and
I usually go with like the most likely
scenario well war is not logical from
your point of view it's it's logical
from the point of point of view of the
people that launched it and if you think
you're gonna lose your regime and end up
dangling at the end of a rope you will
do some [ __ ] like that for your own
survival it may not look like 'el to you
but you have to put yourself in the
opponent that's not what I'm saying
that's that's not really what I was
getting at I was saying that I'm not
saying that it's not logical from my
point of view but I'm just like saying
that from the point of view of just
looking at outcomes in the most logical
way in the way that what is the most
likely outcome how likely is it has this
happened before like accidentally this
all this other kind of stuff just to me
it doesn't look like it was deliberate
that's all I'm saying and and you know
like I said I was I'm suspicious I'm
various what you know and like I said I
might have gone into this and one of the
I think probably the second cuz I was
talking about the smiley face murders
but uh I think the smiley face murders
video that we did was the one that gets
the second biggest largest amount of you
know people arguing that I usually just
take off some like whatever [ __ ]
because it's usually like really badly
spelled and stuff but um I I feel like
the
that happens and I'm not saying that you
know some of the smiley face murders
like these people are dead okay that
they are dead but do I think that there
is a an organized gang of serial killers
running around various US states as well
as many other countries drowning
college-age young wet young men you know
I mean just because that's the method of
killing do this job yeah there's no
motive there I can groove it's just like
it's a dumb idea it's like you know I
I'm not saying that all of them are
accidents maybe some of them were you
know other things maybe some of them
were murders I'm just saying that all of
them weren't and I do feel like it's a
thing where people who don't know
statistics like how many times this has
happened around this particular area
like oh that's that's the kind of stuff
it can look like there's a pattern there
when there's not really a pattern there
so that's all I'm saying all right and
I'm not saying that it won't come out
later that yeah maybe that's what it was
cuz that does happen sometimes yeah that
was what that's what was what well I'm
just burnt to just anything there's just
yeah just anything I'm not I'm not
saying that later on we might not find
out that it was like some conspiracy or
something like that because some things
are I just feel like most of the time
it's not or it's not as big a conspiracy
as it seems like from your surface or
something like that because like I said
you know humans are really good at like
picking patterns out especially if
you're looking for one yeah the reason
why I'm doing it is because I was
trained in a form of warfare that is
obsolete you know what I mean nuclear
[ __ ] apocalypse between the Soviet
Union that's not gonna happen anymore
well we hope that's not happen
well world war two that world war two
style fighting is obsolete and phoebus
landings and tanks and [ __ ] like that
that's that air is gone because nuclear
weaponry kind of made that obsolete then
it became proxy wars for a long time
that kind of became obsolete and it
looks like warfare looks like warfare in
general is now obsolete because it
involves uniformed militaries and
governments have to be accountable to
them it looks like it's been replaced by
a new form of
warfare that involves NGOs lawyers
propaganda corporations and maybe
bioweapons and a bunch of deception
that's a war that's a war that you could
actually wage you're not a man yeah yeah
weird things like you know the NGOs are
doing like things like weaponized mass
immigration you use that instead of
armies you use that instead of bombs you
use it's like something out of James
Bond you know Spectre you start bribing
politicians you get politicians to
invest in your country like our
politicians a lotta more invested in
China you know and a lot of the
corporations are invested in China so
they have a vested interest in China
succeeding you know at the expense of
the United States because they're the
rich people they could always just fly
away to their private islands over and
another side of the earth they're not
really connected to the United States
they don't care if it succeeds or fails
and then you twist that into something
world global domination where your
octopus of corruption just takes over
the entire world and you you rename that
is something friendly like globalism or
you know like open societies that type
of [ __ ] that's just another that's just
a friendly way of you know saying global
domination of corporations and rich
families you know because you know if
you get Rick we're into the
nation-states you get rid of a citizen's
ability to protect themselves in courts
of law against these corporations that
these rich people own that's what I'm
seeing that's the way that's the form of
warfare I'm saying
used to be rich people just controlled
the armies of a government you know well
that's not really doable anymore so they
do it this way yeah I'm not saying yeah
I'm not saying [ __ ] like that doesn't
happen I'm just saying that just from a
general standpoint a lot of conspiracy
theories I just don't buy them okay I'm
so scared I'm I will leave it on the
audience you guys can comment on a in
the in the comment section I'm just
skeptical I'm suspicious of the timing
of everything it's just everything is
accelerated in all happening at
and it's a weird [ __ ] is happening it
looks like an attack but maybe the
attack being launched from a new
generation of warfare that we've never
seen before that's what it looks like to
me yeah and like you saying I'm saying
I'm not saying that's not hoped a
cloaked clandestine warfare straight out
of Spectre out of [ __ ] I don't had a
double-oh-seven
you knows what it looks like to be yeah
I'm not saying that's not possible I'm
just saying I'm just I'm just you know I
think serving judgment I think China's
behind it China and rich people that
have invested in China that's what I
think it is that's the most likely
suspects but we'll see yeah I mean we'll
see how it goes so so what else
anything else we don't know that yet I
got them damn meatballs in the oven
yeah I pre cook them a little bit before
I put them in with sauce that sounds
good yeah yesterday yeah
neat this morning did you did have
breakfast okay so I haven't eaten since
last since yesterday at like six or
seven all right well let me get to it
all right so we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow stay safe out there